Fancy animations and
smooth transitions
are at the core of
modern mobile app design.
While these things may make
beautiful, transcendent
experiences for your
users, it's easy to forget
what they might be costing
you, in terms of performance.
My name is Colt McCanlis.
And writing performant
Android applications
start with the simple
step of understanding
what's going on in
the Android system,
when you update the visual
properties of a view.
Remember that to draw
something on your device,
Android generally needs to
convert all that high-level XML
into some that
the GPU can accept
and use to render to the screen.
This is done with the help
of an internal object called
a display list.
I display list basically holds
all the information needed
to render a view on the GPU.
It contains a list of
any GPU resident assets
that might be needed,
as well as a list
of commands to
execute to OpenGL,
when it's time to render it.
The first time a view
needs to be rendered,
a display list is
created for it.
And when we need to render
that view to the screen,
we execute that display list by
submitting its drawing commands
to the GPU.
If we want to render that
view again in the future,
like if it's position
changed on the screen,
we simply need to execute that
display list one extra time.
However, in the future, if
some visual part of the view
changes, the previous display
list may no longer be valid.
As such, we'll need to go back,
recreate the display list,
and then re-execute it once
again, to update the screen.
But remember this.
Any time the drawing content
of your view changes,
it will repeat this process
of recreating the display list
and re-executing it to the
screen, the performance
of which varies,
depending on how complex
your review actually is.
And depending on the
type of visual change,
there's other impact on the
rendering pipeline as well.
For example, let's say, a text
box suddenly doubles in size,
causing the parent container to
reposition other sibling views,
before updating its own size.
In this case, we've
updated one view,
and it cascaded to other work
that needed to be done as well.
These types of visual
changes require
additional stages of the
rendering pipeline to occur.
See, when the sizing
of your view changes,
the measure phase
will be kicked off.
And it will walk through
your view hierarchy,
asking each view what
its new sizes are.
And if you change the position
of things, call Request Layout,
or if a view group
repositions its children,
the layout phase will kick
off, traverse the hierarchy,
and figure out where
everything needs to be located.
And you need to be conscious
that each one of these stages
takes time to run.
While by themselves, that
may not be impactful,
when there's a sudden
large amount of views that
get invalidated or
repositioned, this
can trigger a large
performance drain, which means,
to improve the overall
performance of your rendering
system minimizing
invalidations in layouts
is a really great
place to start.
Of course, you'll
need some way to get
more specific
information about where
your problems are showing up.
Firstly, you can
get a better sense
of what part of your
rendering pipeline
has issues by turning on the
profile GPU rendering tool
on your device, which
will provide you
with a handy, at-a-glance view
of the time it took to create,
execute, and process portions
of your drawing pipeline.
Secondly, you can get a sense
of what types of invalidations
are occurring in
your application,
by turning on the Show
GPU View Updates option.
Any time and invalidation
occurs in your app,
you'll see invalidated
part briefly flash
red, which can help
you understand what
parts of your screen are
getting invalidated, even
for the simplest of actions.
Thirdly, make sure you're using
Hierarchy Viewer to constantly
check your view
hierarchy and work
to keep it as flat
as possible, trying
to remove any redundant views.
This will help reduce the
overhead of the layout
and measure phases when
they actually occur.
But this is just the beginning.
For more information on reducing
invalidations, flattening
your hierarchy, and
using hardware layers,
check out the rest of the
resources on the Android
Performance Patterns page.
And don't forget to join
the Google community
for more great tips and tricks.
So keep calm.
Profile your code.
And always remember,
perf matters.